[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
نبداها من الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
وبعد الفرز الاولي من الرابح ومن الخاسر
يمكن القول ان الجمهوريين اقتربوا من حسن
ماساه مساله الحصول على الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه الا ان حظوظهم في السيطره على
الغرفه الثانيه في الكونجرس اي مجلس
الشيوخ لا تزالوا معلقه بنتائج الانتخابات
في ثلاث ولايات هي اريزونا نيفادا وجورجيا
فمن سيصل الى الرقم السحري وبالقوف على
اخر تحديث لنتائج الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه في مجلس النواب النواب ووفقا
لشبكه سنان حصل الجمهوريون حتى الان على
2009 مقاعد في ما حصل الديمقراطيون 192
نقطه وتتوقع في عمان ان يحصد الجمهوريون
16 قدم اضافيه
ليصل الاجمالي الى 225 مقعدا بينما سيصل
عدد مقاعد الديمقراطيين الى 2050 اما بشان
المنافسه في مجلس الشيوخ والتي لم تحسم
نهائيا بعد فقد حصد الجمهوريون 49 مقعدا
في ما حصلت ديمقراطيون ثمانيه واربعين فقط
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ثم يكتب
[موسيقى]
اذا تتجه انذار الامريكيين الان الى
ولايتين نيفادا واريزونا التي يتنافس
الجمهوريون والديمقراطيون فيهما على مقاعد
مجلس الشيوخ فيما يتواصل حتى الان فرز
الاصوات في اريزونا تظهر نتائج تقدم
الديمقراطيين بفريق مريح من الاصوات
اكثر من 76 من الاصوات اما في نيفادا وهي
الولايه التي مازالت متاحه تقدم من طفيفه
للجمهوريين بفارق نحو 15 الف صوت بعد فرز
84% من الاصوات نيفادا تبقى معلقه حتى
اللحظات الاخيره فاذا فاز بها الجمهوريون
سيكون لهم خمسون مقعدا في مجلس الشيوخ
مقابله 49 للديمقراطيه
وايضا سيكون علينا انتظار الحسن في ولايه
جورجيا في السادس من ديسمبر في جوله
الاعاده واذا تحققت المفاجاه وربحت
ديمقراطيون هناك مقعد الشيوخ في نيفادا
فسيعود المجلس لقبضتهم مجددا دون انتظار
نتائج الاعاده في جورجيا
[موسيقى]
نتابع مع مراسلين في واشنطن بيرغانم كير
اهلا بك معنا الى ما يرجع السياسيون
والمحللون كذلك عدم حصول اكتساح الموجه
الحمراء
للمحافظين الجمهوريين هو
مناقشه ومحاربه
والديمقراطيين على اساس الغلاء وارتفاع
تكاليف الحياه لم يسمع الامريكيون كثيرا
لهذه الرساله بل من الواضح بحسب احصاءات
الراي بعد عمليه الانتخاب والتحدث الى
الناخبين ان قضيه حقوق المراه قامت بدور
كبير جدا في اكتساب الديمقراطيين المزيد
من الاصوات هناك بعض الكلام الان يقول ان
دور الرئيس السابق دوران ترامب ربما كان
سلبيا في هذه الانتخابات واخرى هذه الموجه
الكاسحه لدى الجمهوريه
الولايات التي لم يحسم فيها السباق يعني
الى اين تتجه الامور وماذا تقول التوقعات
كذلك هل يمكن
بالفعل ان يبقى الشيوخ بحوزه الديمقراطيين
ربما تاخذ مساله انتهاء الفرز عده ايام
اضافيه وبدون شك ان موضوع مجلس الشيوخ لن
يحسم الا مع انتخابات جورجيا في اوائل
الشهر المقبل اي عده اسابيع على الارجح
نحن باتجاه كونغرس منقسم مجلس الشيوخ تحت
السيطره الديمقراطيين مجلس النواب تحت
سيطره
الجمهوريين الجمهوريين يتقدمون الان اقله
في 10 مقاعد دوائر انتخابيه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي وبذلك سوف يحونا على
الاكثريه في مجلس النواب في الغانم من
واشنطن شكرا جزيلا
البطريق
[موسيقى]
العمل
في بني وفرشادير
[موسيقى]
ان نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه ستغير واقع
الامريكيين في الداخل الامريكي في ملفات
عده سيطالها تغيير بعد هذه الانتخابات
سيماها الملفات التي شكلت نقطه خلاف
اساسيه بين الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
ابرزها كيفيه معالجه تضخم المتزايد في
الولايات المتحده حيث طالما شدد
الجمهوريون على ضروره التراجع عن القطط
الانفاق الضخمه
وملف اخر قد ياخذ منحا اخر والحديث هنا عن
خطه بيض لتحديث البنيه التحتيه وهي خطه
التي لم تلقى تايدا من قبل الجمهوريين
ورصفت للخطه حوالي اا تريليوني دولار وهو
المبلغ الذي اعتبره الجمهوريون الضخما
نوعا ما اشتكى الجمهوريون من ان الخطه
تتضمن انشاء محطاته شحن للسيارات
الكهربائيه اكثر من التحديثات الماديه مثل
الطرق والجسور والموانئ والمطرات
ثالث الملفات الداخليه الهامه ملف النفط
حيث ان قرار بيضا الاخير لسحب النفط من
المخزونات التي استراتيجيه لمواجهه تراجع
الامدادات لها رفضا كبيرا من الجمهوريين
لدرجه انهم اطلقوا في مجلس النواب تحقيقا
للنظر في اساءه استخدام محتمله للمخزون
الاستراتي
معنى من واشنطن الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات حسين عبد الحسين السيد حسين
اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
ما هي القضايا الداخليه التي ستتاثر بفوز
الجمهوريين بالاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
مساء الخير اعتقد انه كل القضايا التي
تفضلتها بذكرها هي على طاوله البحر طبعا
هناك اختلاف في فلسفه الحكم بين
الجمهوريين والديكوراطيين يعتبر
الجمهوريون انه على الحكومه الفيدراليه ان
تكون حكومه مصغره وان تناطق الشؤون
الخدماتيه بحكومات الولايات المحليه فيما
يرى الديمقراطيون انه دور الحكومه
الفيدراليه ليس فقط انه ان تكون حكومه
شكليه وانما انت تقوم بدور اجتماعي فاعل
وان تقوم بتوزيع اكبر للسنوات عبر الضرائب
التصاعديه تاخذ من الاغنياء تعطي الى
الفقراء تقدم برامج اجتماعيه هناك اختلاف
جذري في الفلسفه الى الحكم والاقتصاد بين
الاثنين اعتقد ما عوده الجمهوريين الى
مجلس النواب انهم فازوا في الاكثريه
سيحاولون اعاقه البرامج التي قدمها الرئيس
ديمقراطي بايدن وبمساعده يعني الكونجرس
عندما كان في ايدي ديمقراطنين في العامين
الماضيه بيدن كان قلقا على ما يبدو من
اكتساح الجمهوريه
للكونغرس وهو ما لم يحصل صحيح توقعات تقول
انهم سيطرون على مجلس النواب ولكن يعني
ليس بتلك بتلك الاغلبيه الكبيره جدا في
انتظار الحسم ايضا في مجلس الشيوخ وكذلك
لم يتضح بعد ما اذا كان سيحصلون عليها هل
اعلان نيته الترشح للرئاسيات المقبله يعني
انه استعاد بعض الثقه
اعتقد انه هو الان يرى انه ليس هناك غضب
امريكي كما كان يتصور البعض عليه وعلى
الحزب الديمقراطي
وانه يعني
الفوز الجمهوري بمجلس نواب
سيضطر الجمهوريين الى
التوصل لاتفاقيات مع الديمقراطين خصوصا ان
كانت يعني كما يبدو متوقعا ان كانت ال
الغالبيه الجمهوريه ضيقه وبواقع حسنه
مقاعد قليله وهو ما يفرض على الجمهوريين
التواصل مع الديمقراطيه مثلا راينا انه في
العمل الماضيه لانه الغالبيه في مجلس
الشيوخ كانت همم يعني ضيقه جدا 50 مقعد
فقط مع نائبه الرئيس هي التي تحسن اضطر
يعني نجح همم
اثنان في في شيوخ في فرد شروطهما من يعني
همم مثل همم
العضو عن ولايه فرجينيا الغربيه وكذلك عن
ارزان النجاح في فرد همم بنود معينه على
الرغم من انه كل الحزمه الديمقراطي كان
يعرضها فا الاغلبيه الضيقه ليست ناعمه
فعليا بل هي نقمه تجبر الحزب الحاكم او
الحزب المسيطر على المجلس بالتواصل مع
الحزب الاخر لتشكيل اجماع حتى يعني تمر
القوانين او حتى تتحرك الامور نعم طيب
ولكن مساله الانفاق داخل الولايات المتحده
هل ستتاثر حقا برايك في السنتين المقبلتين
طبعا سيكون هناك محاولات عرقله لتمرير
الموازنه والمصادقه عليها وهذا غالبا من
باب الملاكمه السياسيه لكن احد اكبر
الانجازات التي يعني توصل اليها الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب انه نسف الحكمه
الجمهوريه التي كانت تعارض بشكل دائم
الانفاق والاستدانه او دفع الدين العام او
دفع سقف الاستدانه للدين العامه ترامب نسف
هذه هذا التقليد الطويل الجمهوري والان
صار يعني اي من الحسبين في السلطه يعمد
غالبا الاستدانه الى رفع سقف الاستبانه
نعم
ارتفاع التضخط تضخم المرتفع يعني وكذلك
ارتفاع اسعار السلع وكذلك اسعار البنزين
لا شك انه جزء كبير من التضخم الامريكي
سببه كميه الاموال الضخمه التي دخلها
الكونجرس يعني
تطرقتم الى المليارين في قانون البنيه
التحتيه وكان قبل ذلك مليار اا عفوا في
اليونان وكان قبل ذلك تريليون ونصف
وتريليون ونصف اقررها الكونجرس اثناء
رئاسه كل هذه التريليونات يعني الولايات
المتحده انفقت حوالي 10 الى 12 مليون
اثناء ازمه كوبيد وهذا ما يوازي همم يعني
نصف يعني حجم نصف الاقتصاد الامريكي
وعندما تضخ الدوله هذه الكميه من المال
هذا يعني حسما انه البلاد التضخم اعتقد
انه ما رفع الفائده سيتراجع التضخم نوعا
ما هو انت حال حاله الامور حول العالم مثل
في موضوع الحرب في اوكرانيا او في موضوع
يعني همم مخزونات النفط حول العالم اعتقد
انه الامور ستتحل رويدا شكرا جزيلا لك
حسين عبد الحسين الباحث في مؤسسه الدفاع
ديمقراطيه تكون انت معنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
بوادر انفتاح عند روسي واخر اوكرانيه على
التفاضل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد هذه المدينه
الاستراتيجيه في اوكرانيا تسرق الانظار
فبين الانسحاب الروسي المفاجئ منها
والتشكيك الاوكراني بالقرار يبرز تساؤل هل
يمكن ان يعد هذا الانسحاب نصرانيا جديدا
ام تكتيك الروسيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
بدات تجميع قواتها التي انسحبت من خرفه في
مناطق على الضفه اليسرى لنهر ديني برو
بحسب بيان الوزاره لكن قائد الجيش
الاوكراني لا يزال يؤكد انه لا يمكن تاكيد
هذا الانسحاب الروسي بالكامل في اثناء
تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه وتقدمها في
المنطقه الجنوبيه والسعاده السيطره على
اثنتين 10 قريه في خربه اما بالنظر الى
تحركات القوات الروسيه التي اعلنت
الانسحاب من المدينه فقد كشفت صحيفه فاعل
الامريكيه ان قوه الروسيه اقامت مواقع
الدفاعيه لها في اجزاء المتبقيه من خيرسون
جنوب شرق المدينه او اضافه انه لا يزال
هناك ما يصل الى 40,000 جنديه الروسي
متمركزين على الخطوط دفاعيا غرب نهر دنبرو
واشارت الى ان روسيا ارسلت ايضا بعضا من
مقاتليها الاكثر خبره الى المنطقه وخزنت
الذخيره والامدادات الاخرى
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه
سيكون دليلا على التقدم الطويل للقوات
الاوكرانيه ويكشف ضعف الهجوم العسكريه
الروسي الجانبيه اعتبر امين عام حلف شمال
الاطلسي سيشكل نصرا جديدا لاوكرانيا ويعكس
الضغط الكبير الذي تعاني منه القوات
الروسيه
ايس كريم
فور يو
معنى مباشره
عذرا لقد انقطع الصوت قليلا
عنه اليوم
بتحرير اثني عشر مدينه او قريه
وبالاجماليه حاره
في منطقه خرسان ونحن نتقدم بشكل تدريجي
ومستقر نعم لماذا تشكك اوكرانيا في
الانسحاب الروسي من خيرسون سيد يوري
نصف كابتك والله
بانسحابهم لانه ليس ان انسحاب تراجع لان
الجيش الاوكراني منذ عده اسابيع وهو يتسبب
المشاكل جيش الروسي
ضربات جويه عاليه الدقلت عرقلت عملياتهم
اللوجستيه وسلاسل
وفي نفس الوقت
ولم يشهد الى الان حركه كبيره لان الجنود
فما لم نعم نعم غادرت القوات الروسيه فسوف
نستمر
بحجمتنا المضاده وماذا نفعله بكل دقه
وسنتصرف وفقا لخططنا طيب ايه اذا لم يعد
الروس لمهاجمتكم في خيرس من المناطق التي
ينصحبو منها
واستمريتم في التقدم هل يمكن الحديث على
ان خلصن الان باتت نقطه تحول في الحرب في
اوكرانيا
العديد همم
اولها كان بعد ساعتين وبدايه هذا الغزو
يعني الكل كان يعتقد انه كان ستسقطه خلال
72 ساعه ولم تسقط اوكرانيا بكل شجاعه
وقلنا بحمايه عاصمتها
وطردنا العدو والان علينا ان نستمر
وكافه اراضيها ولكن سيد يري هل يمكن ان
يكون هذا الانسحاب الروسي التكتيكي ربما
هو
افتاحا للمجال من اجل التفاوض المباشر ما
بين همم ما بينكم ما بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
لانها هذه الحرب ام لا يعني هذا يعني
مبالغه او يعني همم شيء مثال جدا
نحن
العدو الروسي يرغب بالتفاوض لانهم بحاجه
الى وقف
العمليات هم بحاجه الوقت لاعاده التمويل
والتدريب
للقواتيم او جنودهم الذين حشدهم
مؤخرا لانهم وصلوا الى ساحه المعركه غير
مستعدين باعداد كبيره ومتاكد انك شاهدت
الماضيه الجنود الروسيه
لن تستسلم ابدا ولا تتخلى عن حلمها
باحتلال اوكرانيا وتدميرها ونحن لنا نثق
باي حديث عن المفاوضات ولكن فيما يخصهم
عندنا زهره الاكرانيه يجب ان تستحق
والتعويضات ايرانيه يجب ان تدفع وكل شيء
يجب ان يتم وفقا لمفاق الامم المتحده بعد
ذلك بامكان الجلوس للتحدث ولكن سيد يوري
الا تخشون ان هذا الانسحاب الروسي كما
ذكرتهم انكم يعني تكبدون عشرات القتلى من
الجنود الروسي يوميا الا تخشون ان هذا
الانسحاب المفاجئ من من غير سن يمهد
لاستخدام اسلحه غير تقليديه لان خلص في
النهايه هي بتعتبرها روسيا انها احتلتها
وضمتها الى الى اراضيها بعد الاستفتاءات
التي قامتها قامتها في تلك المنطقه الى اي
حتى تخشون من ان روسيا مقبله بعد هذا
الانسحاب على تغيير منح الحرب استخدام
اسلحه غير تقليديه
رمضان
شامل
فمن هذا المنظور تخوفنا
نحن لا كثيرا ولكن
باعداد كبيره
من اللاعبين الكبار على المسرح الدولي
وقيل لهم واضحه
باستخدام انه تكتيكيه والقنابل القادره
فستكون هذه نهايه روسيا هم يعرفون ذلك ان
يرضعهم ذلك
دفاع الاوكراني شكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه
دعوه العربيه هذا المساء
[موسيقى]
المعارك المتواصله منذ حوالي 10 اشهر كانت
تكلفتها ثقيله على مستوى الخسائر البشريه
فالحرب تسببت في مقتل واصابه نحو المئه
الف جنيه روسي ومثلهم من الجنود
الاوكرانيين منذ بدايه الحرب هذا ما اعلن
عنه الجنرال مارك ميلي رئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه المشتركه والذي كشف ان تقديرات
تشير ايضا الى مقتل 40 الف مدني في هذا
النزاع المسلح وفي سياق اخر تحدث الجنرال
الامريكي عن وجود مؤشرات على استعداد
اكياب للعوده الى المحادثات مع موسكو ما
قد يفتح نافذه على المفاوضات حسب تعبير
يعني
ومن شان المفاوضات قالت وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه اين موسكو مستعده لمناقشه سبل
الخروج من الازمه في العلاقات مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي واكدت المتحدثه باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان اي
مقترحات يجب ان تؤخذ في عين الاعتبار تاخذ
في الاعتبار الوضع على الارض معتبره
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحتاج الى تقويضي
اقتصاده بشكل كامل لارضاء الولايات
المتحده على حد تعبيرها واشارت الى ان
التغيرات الاخيره في خطاب الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع الدعوات للحوار والمفاوضات
بين موسكو اكيد لا تدعمها جهود حقيقيه في
هذا الاتجاه حسب قول زخرف
هذا هو اعلنت الحكومه البريطانيه تجميد
اصول قيمتها ثمانيه عشر مليار جنيه
استرليني تعود لافراد وكيانات روسيا صدرت
بحقهم عقوبات بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا
وزادت الاصول الروسيه المجمده ب 6 مليار
جنيه عن المبلغ المعلن عنه في جميع انظمه
العقبه البريطانيه الاخرى فقال وزير
الخزانه البريطانيه ان الرساله بلاده
واضحه وهي عدم السماح لبوتن بالنجاح في
الحرب باوكرانيا وفقا تعبير
[موسيقى]
ملف نتالي ايران حيث سلط نظام الايراني
حملته القمعيه في الاونه الاخيره ضد
الطلاب مع اتساع الاحتجاجات في الجامعات
والتضامن الواسع من قبل الطلبه مع
الانتفاضه الشعبيه فقد منعت سلطات
الايرانيه بشكل واسعه طلاب المحتاجين من
الدخول الى الجامعات وعلقت دراستهم وفقا
لتقرير لمجالس النقابات الطلاب الايرانيين
وكان نحو 60 استاذ جامعي قد اصدروا بيانا
في وقت سابقا على نوفيه للاحتجاجات التي
وصفوها بالقانونيه للطلاب مشددين على انهم
سيستخدمون جميع القنوات الاحتجاجيه في حال
عدم الافراج عن الطلاب المعتقل
وليس فقط في الجامعات بل وصل الامر الى
المستشفيات والصيدليات ايضا حيث انتشرت
قوات الامن داخلها لملاحقه المحتاجين
المصابين والقاء القبض عليهم وهو ما دفع
بعض الاطباء الى الاعتراض على هذا الوضع
الذي لا يسمح بتقديم المساعدات
انت عرفت للاصابه في الاحتجاجات في ايران
فمن الافضل لك ان لا تلجا لاي مستشفى او
صيدليه ان كنت تريد العوده الى منزلك
سالما هي نصيحه يتبعها المحتاجون في ايران
والسبب هو ان المستشفيات والصيدليات ايضا
اصبحت اشبه بمخافر الشرطه حيث ينتشر فيها
رجال الامن والمخبر الموضوع لم يروق
للاطباء انفسهم حيث بادر البعض منهم الى
تنظيم وقفه احتجاجيه امام المجلس الطبي
اعتراض على وجود قوه الامن في المستشفيات
فضلا عن اعتقال البعض منهم وترهيبهم
الموضوع بلغ حد التخلي عن اداء الواجب
المهني خوفا من بطش قوات الامن ولان
الحاجه تبرر الوسيله فان العديد من
المحتاجين بداوا باللجوء الى اطباء
بيطريين لعلاجه من اصابتهم وذلك لتمويه
رجال الامن
الاكثر من ذلك فان شراء ضماده من الصيدليه
قد يتحول الى تهمه تعرضك للخطر ولضرر اكبر
من الاصابه نفسها فالضماده قد تتحول الى
خيطنا يتبعه رجال الشرطه للكشف عنه هويات
المحتاجين
لكنها غيره اصحاب البذلات البيضاء على
وجههم الوطني دفعتهم الى انشاء شبكه غير
رسميه على الانترنت لتواصل مع المتظاهرين
المصابين ومحاوله مساعدتهم بعيدا عن
مستشفياتنا انتم هيك حرمتها من طرف رجال
الامن وسام الذهبي العربي
معنا من لندن الكاتب المختص في الشان
الايراني الدكتور نبيل الحيدري دكتور نبيل
اهلا بك معنا ماذا يعكس هذا التصعيد من
قبل النظام خاصه ضد طلاب الجامعات في
ايران
تحيه لك استاذ صهيب والمشاهدي قناه
العربيه هذا يعكس خوفا النظام هلا عن
النظام وصل الى هذا العدد لم يحصل له سابق
حقيقه هذه الثوره حقيقه نحن الان في نهايه
الشهر الثاني حقيقه لها كل المظاهرات وصلت
غايتها 10 ايام وقمعت استعملوا مختلف
وسائل القمع استعملوا مختلف البلطجيه
والمليشيات واتهامها بالخارج والعماله
وهمم حتى مسرحيه سجن ايفل واخوهاج
البلطجيه مسرحيه شيراز وضرب وداعش كل هذه
المسرحيات لم تنجح لا زال هذا الجيل
الجديد هذا الجديد الشاب والجامعات
وتتصدامهم بشعار لاول مره الحياه الحريه
يستطيع ان يصل الى هذا المستوى لذلك نجد
والقوه الامنيه تق- قول القيادات
ونضعف النظام الذي لم يستطع حتى
خرج رئيس الحرس الثوي يهددهم ولم ينفع قال
هذا اخوه نعم طيب هذا التهديد يعني هو متى
يقترن بافعال كذلك والملاحقات كما تابعنا
في التقرير السابق باتت تمتد الى
الصيدليات والى المستشفيات كذلك لالقاء
القبض على المحتجين المصابين الذين ينقلون
الى المستشفيات هل تعتقد ان زياده القبضه
الامنيه الا يمكن ان تخيف المحتجين ربما
للتراجع قليلا
هذا ما يعتقده النظام لانه في السابق قام
مع الاحتجاجات من خلال هذه الوسائل ولكن
همم هذا الجيل الجديد بالعكس بمقدار ما
تق- معه بمقدار ما يزداد قوه واباءا كل
ممارسات اثبتت في كل هذه الفتوه انه عنده
قدره على المناوى عنده قدوه على الاستمرار
عنده قدوه على الصمود وعنده قدوه على
التصدي بكل هذه همم الانواع يعني نحن نعلم
انهم لا يذهب المستشفيات ولكن هنالك من
الشعب من الاطباء والممرضات الشريفات
يداوهم في اماكن اخرى حتى ياتون الى
بيوتهم اذا عندما يكون الشعب حقيقه اذا
هذا الدوله من التكاتف كل هذه الوسائل
ملاحقتهم في الصيدليه والمستشفى وحتى
تسببه السيارات الاسعاف استعملك القمع
سيارات عمومي ومع ذلك لم ينجحوا الى الان
ما يحدث الان هذه المظ الحاليه في ايران
لو قررناها بسبقاتها خاصه مظاهرات همم
2019 اين نحن في المقارنه ان كان مع قمع
النظام والوسائل التي استخدمها وكذلك حجم
ومده الاحتجاجات
طبعا لا مجال المقاومه يعني احنا الان همم
الان حدوث الشهوهين لك همم اقل من عشره
ايام وقمعت بشده وايضا لم تصل الى هذا
المستوى من كل طبعا كل المحافظات الان
اشتركت 31 محافظه حتى القوه النائب التي
كان النظام يعتبئها تابعه الان قم المقدسه
ومشهد واماكن همم القيادات في الطاحون
كلها وصلت الى بيت المرشد
ومكتبه همم طبعا هذه اكبر واعظم واكثر زي
زخم واكثر وشموليه لانها تصداها المراه
اولا لم تكن هنالك الجامعات هنا بكل
الجامعات
والطلاب حتى الطلاب الصغار يعني هذه هذه
لم تكن هناك لان عندنا كثره المدارس
الابتدائيه والثانيه كلها اشتغلت شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور نبيل الحيدري انتم الكاتب
المتخصص في شان الايراني كنت معنا منظر
[موسيقى]
وعلى وقع هذه الاحتجاجات دعا مجلس النواب
البلجيكي دول الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبه
اضافيه
حول دور الحرس الثوري الايراني في قمع
الاحتجاجات المندلعه في منذ سبتمبر الماضي
هذا وقد فرض وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي في ما سبق عقبه عدد من المسؤولين
الايراني
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا في ما يبدو لدينا مجموعه من
الاخبار العاجله نقل عن الرئيس الامريكي
اذن جو بايدن اذا الذي يتحدث في هذه
اللحظات اذا هو يقول لم تحدث موجه حمراء
في الانتخابات المصريه يقصد لم يحصل
اكتساح جمهوري الذي يتميز طبعا باللون
الاحمر في انتخابات
الكونغرس اذا يقول ان الانتخابات النسبيه
كانت نزيهه وكشفت عن يوم رائع
الديمقراطيه اذا نحن نتابع اذا هذه الكلمه
اللي همم الرئيس اذا الذي يقرر اذا كذلك
بخساره الديمقراطيين لمقاعد في مجلس
النواب طبعا في ظل تقدم الجمهوريين همم
هناك بفارق اذا منيح بالنسبه للجمهوريين
ولكنه همم يعني لم تحصل موجه حمراء كما
يقول همم الرئيس
انه لم يحصل اكتساح جمهوري
لغرفه مجلس النواب والكونغرس غرفتين
الكونجرس مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ اذا
وبايدا يقرر الان بخساره الديمقراطيين
المقاعد في همم
مجلس النواب ويقول ايضا سنقبل نتائج
الانتخابات النصفيه في هذا العاجل ايضا
اذا
نكتفي بهذا القدر اذا مما يقوله الرئيس
الامريكي اذا بعد همم نتائج نتائج الاوليه
اذا الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
ونعود الى شان الايراني حيث شدد المدير
العام لوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه رفاعي
القروسي على ان اعلان طهران تصنيع صواريخ
البالستيه يفاقم المخاوف الدوليه من
برامجها الصاروخيه وشرفت قمه المناخ في
شرم الشيخ الى عدم تسجيل اي تقدم في
المحادثات مع ايران بشان مواد نوويه غير
معلن عنها في ثلاثه مواقع مع وجود خطه
لاجراء زياره الى طهران هذا الشهر
الاخضر او ما اذا كنا نحرز تقدما في
تحقيقاتنا المفتوحه وليس سرا اننا لم
نتمكن من تسجيل بعض العناصر الملموسه
لدينا فرصه لاعاده المشاركه او لمواصله
عملنا ولكن هذا سيحدث بعد صدور تقاريره
[موسيقى]
في فرنسا فجرت ازمه الوقود وارتفاع
الاسعار احتجاجات الواسعه في البلاد منذ
مده المحتجون رفعوا السقفه ونظم العاملون
في قطاع النقل اضرابا شله حركه المواصلات
في باريس
وتحسين ظروف العمل
[موسيقى]
تسبب بشلل تام في وسائل النقل خطان فقط من
اصل 15 من خطوط المترو الفارسيه يعملان
بشكل طبيعي لانهما اوتوماتيكيان ولا
يحتاجان اما الخطوط المتبقيه فخمسه منها
على الاقل توقفت بشكل كامل فيما تعمل
البقيه في ساعه فقط ويتزمن وهذا الاضراب
الذي يحمل مطالب زياده
وتحسين ظروف العمل مع تظاهرات دعا اليها
الاتحاد العام للعمل وقال ان نحو 200 نقطه
تطهر خرجت في عموم انحاء البلاد استجابه
لهذه الدعوه
من الاشخاص يحتكرون الثروه وفي الوقت ذاته
هناك اشخاص يعملون من اجل كسب قوت معيشتهم
هذا ليس مجرد تسيرا لامور المعيشه
بالمحاوله للنجاه من هذا الوضع
مفتوحا هو امر وارد لكنه ينتظر نتائج
المفاوضات مع الحكومه فائده العربيه باريس
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه نتابع طالبان
تقيدوا حريه النساء اكثر فاكثر بعد
التعليم والسفر ممنوع التمزح
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
من السودان حيث اكدت الاليه الثلاثيه
المكونه من الامم المتحده ومنظمتي الاتحاد
الافريقي والايجاد استلامها قبل اسبوعين
وثيقه من المكون العسكري تتضمن تعليقاتهم
وتعديلاتهم على مسوده الوثيقه الدستوريه
لنقابه المحامين
اساسيه تم التوصل اليها مع المكون المدني
مضيفه انها ستدعو الى محادثات مباشره وغير
مباشره خلال الايام المقبله لترجمه
التفاهمات التي تم التواصل اليها كما دعت
هلاليه الثلاثيه جميع الاطراف هل الالتزام
الكامل باحكامه والروح الاتفاق الذي يتم
التوصل اليه والعمل معا لحمايته وتنفيذه
[موسيقى]
لم يبقى لهنا متنفس الافغانيات حرمنا من
حقوقهن في التعليم السفر واللباس والان
حتى في الترفيه حركه طالبان زادت القيود
على المراه ومنعت اخيرا الافغانيات من
دخول المنتزهات والحدائق العامه في
العاصمه كابول ومن شان هذا القانون الجديد
الذي دخل حيزه تنفيذ هذا الاسبوع تقييد
حريه المراه في ظل حكم طالبان التي منعتهن
من السفر دون مرافق واجبارهن على وضع
الحجاب والبرقع واغلقت المدارس للفتيات
اكثر من مره وقبل القرار بخيبه امل لدى
النساء ومشغلين منتزهات الذين استثمر
بكثافه في تطوير هذه المراه
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم
ولايات الامريكيه الداخليه
الانسحاب الروسي ومن خرس نصر لكيف ام
تكتيك لموسكو اوكرانيا لا تزالوا تشكك
وتدعو قواتها للحذر
[موسيقى]
النظام الايراني يصلط حمله القمع ضد
الطلاب ويغلق الجامعات والامن يتخثر في
المستشفيات
لاعتقال المحتجين المصابين
[تصفيق]
خميس اسود في باريس اضراب شامل في قطاع
النقل يشل حركه المواصلات والمترو
وتظاهرات تطالب برفع الاجور
[موسيقى]
كانت هذه اخبار الساعه لهذا الخميس شكرا
لكم على المشاهده نعود ونلتقي الاحد باذن
الله الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]